Avant de participer à TED, et d'être parmi vous,
je n'en avais pratiquement jamais parlé.
Parce qu'en tant que journaliste,
je suis plus encline à écouter vos histoires,
qu'à partager les miennes.
Je n'ai pas encore fait une enquête sérieuse sur mon passé.
Je n'ai pas rempli des tonnes de requêtes,
ni interviewé qui que ce soit.
Je n'ai pas encore retrouvé ma tatie.
Je ne connais pas sa version, ni sa vie aujourd'hui.
Mon histoire aujourd'hui est chaotique et inachevée.
Mais elle reflète bien la situation chaotique et inachevée d'aujourd'hui
à propos de la traite des personnes.
Nous sommes tous des parties prenantes.
Par conséquent, nous faisons tous partie de la solution.
Nous pouvons réfléchir à comment construire un monde plus juste,
et transmettre nos histoires.
Unissons nos efforts pour agir comme nous aurions dû le faire
dès le départ.
Racontons ensemble cette histoire.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)